By son and I are both patients of yours, he is for acting and myself for cancer.
We are on similar diets being gluten and dairy-free.
Is it okay to eat a food that does not have gluten in it but is—but on the label
it says, processed in a facility with wheat, etc.
He can't have sore gum or sesame seeds, and lots of labels have the warden on them, so
we aren't sure if he could eat it if sore gum and sesame seeds weren't an ingredient, but
it was still made in a facility that processed those things and may be different for him
with acne versus me with cancer.
So it depends on how reactive a person is.
So many people that show a lot of antibodies, so if they do is Cyrex-3x and Cyrex-4, and
they show a lot of antibodies on the 3x, which is the gluten and gliated antibody and the
gliated peptide tests.
So you're testing different peptides for gliated and you're—and he sent them to a lot
of those things, he could—there's so in it says, the food says it's made in a facility
with these things, but it is gluten-free because it doesn't have any gluten in the ingredients.
It means that there could be cross-contamination.
So it's really buyer-beware of those things, so for a period of time you may want to even
stay away from those things.
I've had people that are full of celiac and the difference between that and a gluten sensitivity
is a celiac person that's had a biopsy of their testicle, wall, and they have—you know,
shows the antibodies to gliated, then some of those people can't even walk by a bakery
and breathe in any gluten dust, and they'll—because they'll have a reaction.
So, but again, when people are dealing with something like this, it's not necessarily noticing
any type of reaction, non-celiac patients, but trying to really clean out their gut.
So for a period of time, you may want to choose to be more careful of cross-reactive foods
as well.
And then you get to a point where you don't have to be careful of those cross-reactive foods.
So yeah, it's a hard question to answer.
You want to be a purist that you're staying away from anything if it's made, even in a factory
with those things.
Certainly, when I tell you to stay away from gluten as a cancer patient, then you don't
have to take that kind of worry of that.
We're talking about gluten being a driver.
If there's cross-contamination, it's not enough to cause any cancer-driving capabilities.